[Musik]
schweizer erfolgsgeschichte wie
präsentiert sich die schweizer qualität
überall auf der welt
carlos marbach bringt käsereien in der
mongolei zum erfolg auch philomena
schwab ist auf der gewinnerseite
sie ist die überfliegerin der schweizer
gamer szene claudio caluori liebt ein
leben am limit
seine bike strecken erobern die welt
ihre geschichten sind schweizer
erfolgsgeschichten grenzenlos gut es
sind menschen die ganz nach oben wollen
menschen wie nino schurter die
weltmeister oder olympiasieger werden
aber auch menschen wie claudio caluori
die im schatten der sieger ihren eigenen
olymp erklimmen und dabei
erfolgsgeschichte schreiben auf dem
gipfel seiner sportlerkarriere hat
caluori diese gegen eine
unternehmerkarriere getauscht
[Musik]
intensiv arbeiten und intensiv genießen
das ist ganz nach clooneys geschmack
der ex profi mountainbiker claudio
caluori holte siebenmal den schweizer
titel bevor er eishockey downhiller und
pumptrack bauer wurde
[Musik]
heute sind seine bike strecken kult
auf 1100 metern höhe in flims sind die
zentrale und das zuhause des 42-jährigen
hier tüftelt er an seinem neuesten
projekt kann sowohl am morgen
funktionierte wie auch sport aber träge
der sport habe letzte nacht ich glaube
du bist angegangen und dann zum heimat
wird am 6 ich war gefangen sondern ist
dem sie leben am limit
das machte claudio auch schon als profi
biker kein berg zu steigen
kein risiko zu groß
vor elf jahren beendete claudio seine
erfolgskarriere und hat eine neue
gestartet zusammen mit seinem team plant
und baut er spezielle bike strecken
das geschäft ist lukrativ im crew der
erste track aus asphalt bauten und
fertig ist das sweet sweet & global und
ziemlich explodiert und den vom track
ich eigentlich bahnschwellen und
steilwandkurven wo man kann mit dem bike
mit dem bmx mit inlineskates und
skateboards und was auch immer
kammer fahrer man muss dazu nicht trennt
sondern das land wenn durch die
verschiedene wellen bat darum heißt
pumptrack das ist ein in new york an
bauten gerade direkt an der williamsburg
bridge
das ist washington das ist in der tat
und das thailand iran japan der
kambodschanischen grenze als er gehört
zum fotos texte eingebaut dass wir den
nächsten tagen gut inzwischen 160 tracks
und wenn oma 1060 dazu akku und dann
noch mal mit ja
beim käsen macht carlos marbach keiner
etwas vor
seit jahrzehnten trägt er das alte
schweizer handwerk in die welt hinaus
von südamerika bis in die mongolei
so verhilft eher kleinen unternehmen zum
großen erfolg
[Musik]
in der mongolischen hauptstadt ulan
bator in der heimat von dschingis khan
haben sie jetzt den käse den schweizer
käse aller mongolei das ist unser pro
tier hier ich weiß wie ich daraus proben
kabellos marbach ist einer der weiß wo
es langgeht
auf der straße und im leben ganz rechts
jetzt weiter dort wo der rote geht ja
ich weiss man bogen können nicht
unterscheiden zwischen rot und grün
der 75-jährige ist ein mann der klaren
worte
keine weiß das so gut wie nah ran tui
bat seine mongolische übersetzerin und
dritte ehefrau
seit zehn jahren kommt käse profi
tadellos hierher und hilft seinen kunden
wirtschaftlich auf die beine
wie enki adam suhlen der vier käsereien
und fünf restaurants besitzt der
gelernte metall erschien ihr hat in
düsseldorf gearbeitet und deutsch
gelernt mit carlos kann er stundenlang
fachsimpeln
das ist ziemlich nicht so einfach
managen
vielleicht vielleicht im schweiz ist es
einfacher weil ihr habt die macht das
schon 1000 jahre sorgen diese ist nicht
das einzig typisch schweizerische für
das kader steht jahre lang war er für
das schweizerische
katastrophenhilfekorps und das dessauer
unterwegs der heiße sommer stellt die
käser wo ein problem zu wenig wasser zu
wenig gras zu wenig milch bekommt
unterstützung ki ist vater von fünf
kindern
[Musik]
carlos der sohn eines landarbeiters ist
von den mongolischen pferden fasziniert
sie haben den winter in freiheit
verbracht und sind nicht mehr an
menschen gewöhnt aber die sind ganz wild
[Musik]
virtuelle fantasiewelten sind ihre
spezialität
philomena schwab ist die wohl
profilierteste ging entwicklerin der
schweiz eine anfrage des silicon valleys
hat sie abgelehnt
denn die 29 jährige träumt davon die
schweiz zu einem kleinen silicon valley
zu machen
[Musik]
als einer der einflussreichsten jungen
game entwicklerinnen weltweit lobte sie
das amerikanische wirtschaftsmagazin
forbes es gibt sehr viel game studios
was probiert und was wird eine quizshow
recht herr zum krampf forums oder der
game studios philomena schwab hat das
brief von studio vor drei jahren
mitbegründet
heute arbeiten hier zehn junge künstler
das hat zukunft denn die game porsche
ist weltweit lukrativer als die
filmbranche omega gezeichnete als mega
realistisch und auch ganz eigentlich
drin was mir der unwirtliche weltraum
über mehrere tage oder wochen sogar das
ist spitze postapokalyptisches parteien
kein gerades bz dem momentanen eine
klima thema ein bojan stark beschäftigt
und ich glaube auch bericht vom studio
dank des vorspanns thema aufgriff umwelt
biologie und genetik das erste spiel von
philomena war ein riesenerfolg
eine million franken brachte es ein geld
das sie für die entwicklung neuer
spieler einsetzt und wenn ich sie jetzt
auf deinen nacht schlafen an ein konzert
jungtiere und spannendem spiel ich
eigentlich dass es seine familie bauen
gibt und dass jedes tier wirklich sie
eigene gehen hat also sagen wir jetzt
das gehen von der mutter gehen wird und
gehen vom vater und man die noch eines
rinds anhand dann wird das neu gemischt
also wirklich funktioniert die genetik
und das definiert dann halt was ich bei
google traumfigur kann ich laufe wie gut
kann ich kämpfe nicht unter wasser stufe
jetzt kann ich mich eingriff der insel
die sehr friedlich
was auffiel dass ich gut anwachsen kann
ich liebe vorbereitet sie mich wieder
bewegung des babys bibel man probiert
ist es nützlich das lernspiel wird wie
funktioniert jetzt die ganze
vererbungslehre mit dominanter rezessive
gehen und 6 x chromosom zu wittern
sondern umweltschutz liegt oder bei
finchers erwehren dem spieler viele
träumt von einem game ab und weil alle
ihr bestes geben bezahlt sie den anderen
und sich gleich viel um die 5000 franken
im monat
[Musik]
die mongolische steppe ist weit
carlos und enke legen für ihre milchkühe
viele kilometer zurück das ist jetzt
noch von gestern und vorgestern und
letzte konzert nicht betroffen da oben
und das spezialität von daher dass hier
[Musik]
das ist aber auf bahn bild zeit ist das
schlammloch jetzt die freiheit das sei
jetzt in die garten und ist braucht man
sehr überrascht als uns morgen geht es
noch herrscht ein paar frühjahr die
hirten erhält umgerechnet 25 rappen pro
liter so viel kostet wie ein gut die
milch tour sieht sich hin
die nomaden leben weit verstreut und
sind selbstversorger ihre grundnahrung
besteht aus fleisch und milch
zum nächsten
[Musik]
haben wir einen guten tag ich staunte so
mit sättigung wurde die sehr gute
qualität macht hat vorbildlich carlos
liebte sein wissen zu teilen sondern
bodenständig abreißen oder und etabliert
war einfach super schaffen und die
kritik ein kompromiss wenn von 50 jahre
oder noch mehr staub wirtschaft in der
schweiz aus preis der besten chaotischen
hauptpreise spezialität den großteil der
milch geben die nomaden den jungtieren
mit dem rest machen sie nahrungsmittel
für den winter abgeben können sie nicht
viel
[Musik]
ja und ja die daumen
diese käserei gehört zum kloster am
alaska land definitiv vor zehn jahren an
käse zu produzieren
aber es gab probleme das änderte sich
als er carlos als coach holte
[Musik]
der schweizer alex arbeitet auch für ngn
alles nicht ob boden als die geräte nein
das gratulieren
doch ehe man sich's versieht wird aus
luke tadel
wer hierbei arbeitet er arbeitet wie
heißt sie täglich kommen wagens hier
habt ihr enkel gesagt auch für zu
stellen
[Musik]
nur auf drei strom hier ist nicht stabil
also wir wollen nicht forcieren nur auf
gott anderem im freien
die unabhängige stiftung swisscontact
bezahlt carlos den flug und einen
symbolischen lohn
sie setzt auf freiwillige ältere
experten wie ihn die handwerk und damit
den erfolg in die welt tragen
wir machen die man auch was passiert sie
früher kommt sie mit aber sie von
krankheitstagen sechs tage und die damit
vor stabilisation die abtöten der sport
so lange zu machen so dass die tsg
kompromiss mit der politik
ja das muss diese auch dürfen die war es
dann eine schrecksekunde unter carlos
strengen regime ging das buddhistische
opferrituale glatt vergessen
dieses versäumnis holten kies
schwiegermutter sofort nach denn die
ersten tropfen milch gehören stets den
göttern
[Musik]
nahe der südafrikanischen stadt durban
liegt das township chester jung
hier finden zwei von drei einwohnern
keine arbeit
genau hier braucht es einen pump track
ist claudio caluori überzeugt mein sport
zum friedlichen zusammenleben beitragen
schnell das muss geklärt werden
[Musik]
der chef schont sich nicht obwohl es
beim asphaltieren bis zu 60 grad heiß
wird dieser bruthitze zehrt an den
nerven
fotoapparate vom asphalt den caritas der
unmöglichkeit
dann machen wir sind die malerischen am
tag noch einmal mehr 20 er
[Applaus]
wasserdicht und borkow und es gibt ein
riesiger markt und ist stets erklärt
carmen eigene fahren aber nur machen
drei männer gehören zu cannes uhr liest
ihm zehen sind einheimische hilfskräfte
wissen am ende
[Musik]
wir müssen was ändern und aufhören eine
schubkarre in zehn minuten so geht das
einfach nicht
wir müssen hier vielleicht aufhören
wir stecken total in der scheiße
callies notruf an den lokalen baumeister
zeigt sofort wirkung
a
als der sohn mit seiner maschine ich
sagen gleich
man kann ja auch ohne zusammenschießen
aber auf einmal kommen zusammen 13
sekunden
wie sagt man bitte danke
der auftrag für den track kommt von der
stadt
er soll ein treffpunkt für alle werden
[Musik]
er ist der inoffizielle chef des
townships und unterhält eine art
privatarmee
mit so einem stellt man sich besser gut
denkt wohl auch kuwait
das war hart heute ja ich hab's gesehen
nahm einige arbeiter gingen einfach weg
wir stellen sicher dass uns niemand
dazwischen punkt ich habe zwölf soldaten
wir müssen über alles was in unserer
gemeinde geschieht bescheid wissen
wir sind überall dabei 30 prozent eines
jeden projektes geht an uns
[Musik]
weil der pumptrack für kinder armer
familien gedacht ist hat credit die
planungsarbeiten nicht verrechnet für
die fertigstellung bleibt ihnen gerade
noch 1 tag
zurück nach zürich die game entwicklerin
philomena schwab wohnt in einer wg in
schwamendingen zusammen mit mutter
ursula am 1 die beiden lassen sich viel
freiheit zum glück ursula hat ihre
tochter alleine großgezogen
das haushaltsbudget war knapp viele
haben mutter und tochter immer geliebt
macht brettspiele die virtuelle welt ist
ihr fremd
für viele ist es inspirierend kilometers
mutter stand immer hinter ihr
das ist also berechtigt vielleicht aber
dass sie hilfe
keystone das macht eigentlich schon
dankbar für sie wenn der serie die
software für mich wichtig dass sie das
tut und dass er die liegenschaft ist es
immer ein wunsch von mir viel mist aber
auch die smarte jungunternehmerin hat
einen wunsch gibt verschiedene sachen
gern mitmachen will mehr geld hätten wo
ich muss kurz
dann würde mir sicher das ganze projekt
auf
na ja also bei mir egal was kommt ich
rauf und den studierenden ich kann dem
spiel nur wenn man game designer david
russ
ein mensch der sich in der schweiz in
den käse verliebte ließ hier eine
käserei erbauen um diese festlichkeit
selber herzustellen
[Musik]
er holte enki dazu
und dieser bat carlos im hilfe für
carlos muss er lediglich kost und logis
[Musik]
nicht alles fließt alles noch mal alles
muss immer gleich groß machen
viel volk schreiben
10 53
[Musik]
so wenden es ist alles in ordnung
dass tradition der erst direkt mit ihm
auch die nicht wieder
aber morrissey kreisrund sie
der käse ist weit herum beliebt und
unternehmer enki darf auf baldigen
gewinn hoffen
[Musik]
die liebesgeschichte von maria und
carlos nahm in der mongolischen steppe
ihren anfang
das war vor 15 jahren warum haben sie
gefragt warum nutzt wirklich nützlich an
ihrem operieren und dann habe ich die
rolle der schweiz war hier operiert
kontakt aufgenommen
[Gelächter]
die herzoperation war 2004 sechs jahre
später haben die beiden geheiratet
auch das eine erfolgsgeschichte
in der südafrikanischen stadt durban
muss claudio caluori in aller frühe sein
tagesprogramm ändern um halb sechs ist
mein flug ich muss um halb fünf dasein
von chester will es sich spätestens um
halb drei wegfahren in thailand soll ein
weiterer pumptrack entstehen
der sponsor will claudio vorher in
london treffen das erhöht den druck
üblich ich hoffe alles bleibt bei der
stunde wenn es mehr als erstaunt werden
willst dann alles noch richtig fertig
kriegen bevor in moskau eine banane und
[Musik]
janina ist da den müde von gestern
ja das war knochenarbeit nur noch ein
schock dann sind wir fertig da muss ich
zwei stunden raesfeld es fängt da drückt
muss in den vier stunden fertig sie nein
weniger als vier stunden also irgendwie
wird sie beziehen realistisch
doch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der närrische zeit am limit ist am
schönsten und sagt jetzt ganz viel mit
konstant
[Musik]
der selbsternannte quartier chef
bereitet schon mal das anstehende
barbecue vor
[Musik]
daher setze ich gut wenn alles super
schütze michael wende nicht
hier war vielen dank möchte ich die
fleisch nein bin immer noch vegetarier
na dann alles gute bis bald
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
auch in der kroatischen stadt dubrovnik
gilt ohne fleiß kein preis
philomena schwab und ihr freund don
walker der ebenfalls erfolgreich spiele
entwickelt haben viel vor
jetzt laufen zwölf meter gehen
nachfolgenden unterzieht und
anschmiegsam ab so lange habe man sie
zum erzähler investoren und publisher
[Musik]
die reboots ist eines der weltweit
grössten game entwickler treffen viele
einflussreiche menschen kommen hier
zusammen
philomena nutzt die gunst der stunde ich
bin mit gründerin und spiel entwicklerin
von straight studio wir sind ein kleines
team von zehn personen in zürich und wir
arbeiten in unserem zweiten spiel das
nimbus der weltraum erbauer heißt was
ist sympathisch es ist ein action
simulation skate
[Musik]
das spiel finanziert sich im frühstadium
selbst aber wir suchen die unterstützung
von publishers vor allem in asien
dort gibt es viel potenzial bezüglich
distribution & marketing und wir sind
auch für andere vorschläge offen
[Applaus]
wir sind chinesische publisher
faszinieren ein großartiges spiel
das hat riesenpotenzial der pool lockt
aber erfolg fordert einsatz
bereits um 15 uhr ist viel - nächster
auftritt
[Musik]
seit ich zunächst ich will in der nähe
zum mega tv evers begrüße sache
überhaupt
aber die sache wo ich wirklich selber
sehr interessiere dann schon ziemlich
also dem motto sorge dass sie ein guter
tag geben damit ich eine solidarität
verschwanden will die hockete extra
halbstündiger und wann ich sondern wir
sind sonst für keller eines studiums
schauen wer gehört werden will muss gut
auftreten viele habe sich das an
trainieren müssen sagt sie heute gibt
sie selbstbewusst tipps wie man sich die
trierer game sicher der aufbau einer
gamer gruppe wichtig für finanziellen
erfolg wir denken ja wir wussten mit
50.000 kopien erreichen wir die
gewinnzone und wir machen den spielern
klar wenn wir das nicht hinkriegen ist
schluss mit updates dann schrieben wir
ihnen vorschläge wie sie uns
unterstützen können
wendet euch an eure lieblings
youtube-stream euren lieblings kanal
postet es auf den sozialen medien und
bringt es unter die leute um sie machten
uns bekannt indem sie uns überall
verwenden
[Applaus]
auch in dieser branche ist networking
teil des erfolgs
können wir ein bild von uns machen
ich bin ein blogger nach diesem
ereignisreichen tag hat die
jungunternehmerin endlich einen moment
für sich so als teenager nehmen
das muss ich heute ganz dagegen bis
machen wo irgendetwas mir seit sollte
ich jetzt gerade spannend finden habe
ich gar nicht cool gefunden wenn ich bis
am schluss auch immer meine eigene
entscheidung treffen meine eigene
konsequenzen tragen
dann bin ich ganz zufrieden genauso
klingt erfolgreiches unternehmertum
[Musik]
auch claudio kann einen erfolg verbuchen
nach seinem 48 stunden trip nach london
hat der thailändische investor den
vertrag unterzeichnet
also sagte denis wenn er fertig ist oder
inzest festival braucht wenig an die
rote linie und als logan man mal was
große lauf seine pumps eröffnen den
kindern eine neue welt glaubt er daran
hatte ihnen diese anlage letztes jahr
geschenkt oder einer bremse ist
blockiert projekt du hättest gewinnen
können
jetzt läuft's galerie sponsert das
mädchenteam ich liebe es hier leute zu
treffen
vorher konnte ich nicht mit fremden
menschen sprechen aber diese scheue habe
ich überwunden
jetzt kann ich mit allen sprechen so wie
ich das gerade mit claudio tun
barista wie wie google sich 13 jähriger
im griff
usd
[Musik]
hallo hofft dass die mädchen später an
einem weltcup teilnehmen können
es ist ganz egal woher das kommen was
für 3 was für herkunft sie hand- und wo
es wohnen und sie hat einfach immer
freut
[Musik]
ja es macht mir eben ist sehr emotional
muss mir ganz emmerich
[Musik]
es geht nicht anders als wenn das was
man außer arbeit an dem lied freut macht
das ist okay das ist der hammer
[Musik]
noch mehr schweizer erfolgsgeschichten
in einer woche eines der bekanntesten
stickerei unternehmen der schweiz führt
caroline forster als co-ceo in vierter
generation sogar michelle obama trägt
diese kreationen hans rudolf herren hat
in afrika millionen von menschen vor dem
hungertod bewahrt werde clinton prinz
charles und margaret thatcher danken es
ihm
simon rindlisbacher ist
fünf-sterne-hotel die in vietnam sein
personal weiß qualität geht ihm über
alles
das ist sein erfolgsrezept
[Musik]
präsentiert wurde die schweizer qualität
überall auf der welt